three times Super Bowl champion 14
seasons in the NFL undrafted in 83 and
my breakfast friend who we eat breakfast
almost every day in the country together
and he's gonna be my neighbor so I'm
gonna go jog by his house cuz he's not
gonna jog and I'm gonna pick him up and
we're gonna walk and have breakfast
that's our life we're gonna get old
together and just sit up there face each
other over cup of coffee and just talk
about each other like a dog that's our
plan Nate how you doing buddy
I'm doing great manners you picked me
out man that sure would be nice man
well I can't pick you up like the
picture they have in our studio I could
pick you up
because that's the little Nate Newton
but you've grown a little bit you know
about the time when after you after you
lost all the weight and you came to my
door and I didn't recognize you
recognized Nate Nate came to my rung my
doorbell and and I recognized the voice
but I didn't recognize the person he had
lost that much weight so you thought
some random dudes voice I took his head
I mean he said the same hit you well
over 200 yeah and I what did he do with
all the underwear that's the first thing
act like what do you do it all 54 what
happened speaking of needing them again
what happened to you Cowboys yesterday
cuz you work with the Cowboys Cowboys
what happened to your Cowboys that was a
total physical whooping they took and
they had were you there I went back in
loot yeah I went back and looked at that
film of their offensive line with
Quinton Nelson in the center Kevin other
guys man and they were running a couple
of power plays on short raps long tries
to kept cutting the defense you know the
Cowboys defense is a speed to get out
and run and they are able to do that
when they're into you're lying
Jesus the line plays well well but
lumen log which I call Antoine woods
Malik Islands Ross and all those guys
didn't play very well so that didn't
allow feeling spills and uh the young
veterans to be able to run I mean it
they gobble them up and it was it was a
physical game both of our offensive line
in which both cases they didn't fare too
well
they explained to the country how in the
world could you quarterback throw for
over 400 Zeek go for over 100 and Cooper
go for over 200 and we get no
productivity either either of them
yesterday how does that happen
oh man you know that that is that is not
being mature enough and understanding
the situation and where you sit and uh
as far as what you have to do to
accomplish your your goals and their
goal is to win the NFC who's that on
like who is that on the players the
coach who's that on because it seemed
like they were ill-prepared on the
coaches and the leaders of the team
beyond you know that we play we play you
guys microview troy Emmitt the way y'all
prepared where y'all kept everybody
ready to go not tight but loose and
ready to go and we were big game hunters
to you guys we were allowed to be big
game honors they have no big game hannes
they have nobody that they can look at
and say hey fellas this is where it gets
tough that this is where the rubber
meets the road
let me take you there so zika's not Zeke
is not that guy who is a running back
that relies on others see the others
didn't play well so he cannot cannot
dominate and as much as much as we like
to think that he can do all and cannot
do all the quarterback didn't make
enough plays with his primary receiver
and Cooper they didn't have a not one
chunk play of 20 yards more their
longest completion was 18 yards and that
was still a tight inning you being you
both know you can't win a game with a
tight unless you Gronkowski that's the
only guy thinking his league and maybe
calluses
as a tight end that can change game
around and maybe win it but why
receivers and make enough big craze but
the public is saying how can you show us
so much good then over the last several
weeks and then you look like garbage on
this week that's what the public wants
to know how can that happen
and I will repeat to your public which
you make on the side and you serve does
a great job only show a reason it didn't
matter out the nation is they are not
mature they don't understand it the
enormity of it and I can say they don't
have a big game on it somebody that you
just trying to lose and I and I keep
beating around the bush but their
quarterback is not there so ok I'm glad
you said that
so if your quarterback is not there he
has a payday coming up and it's
something we just we just we've just
focused on [ __ ] some of these
quarterbacks make this type of money
because he's gonna make a hundred
million dollars but yet in steel no no
you warned why won't he he won
you cannot give him 100 million dollars
because if they won't somebody else will
ok alright if you if you believe that
that's fine but if you want to be
successful you have to understand who
your quarterback is and what and what he
can and cannot do and at this point in
time in his career what are you gonna
pay for what you think is gonna happen
or what you see is happening Nate so you
don't think the guy's gonna make at
least 20 he's not gonna make from 20 to
30 million dollars a year next year this
is the for average quarterback right now
it's 20 to 30 million dollars a year let
me say this cry and I'm saying it as a
friend it's a 20 or less million dollar
player the kid at Denver is the same yes
everybody got a little carried away
we're trying to give weather or money so
their teams can suffer but I pray and
hope that Jerry Jones and I call him mr.
Jones does not go out and get it here
this type of money pay him for what
see here's the quarterback that deserves
13 to 15 million dollars it's a lot of
quarterbacks are overpaid in this league
don't wreck your team to say that you
got a twenty million dollar quarterback
and you barely can make the class I'm
looking at the Vikings right now so they
tell me decided to pay eighty four
million dollars that's not right
he's supposed to be able to UM come it
was there to cover all wounds and their
badness he's not been able to do that
when this team has been down he's been
down with the team he's not putting it
it's on it four or five quarterbacks in
his league I can put a team on his back
and take them where they need to go
so is this team a playoff team don't
have how would this team fare in the
playoffs will they still win oh yes time
they're good home team and that's it if
they have to go anywhere outside of the
confines of our Frisco Texas Arlington
Texas they may not fare well at all I
mean this is a home team they're young
they they're not mature you had an
understanding that you have to alpha dog
not only in your backyard but when you
walk outside the gates and they're not
doing a very good job of that so this
team you feel like if they have to go on
the road pretty much what you're saying
is they're going to be as long as they
have a home game they may win yeah that
could happen now prime you know it's
hard me to say that my Cowboys don't get
beat but that could happen if they know
if they don't pull up their bootstraps
and understand that this this league is
a bunch of grown men this is a bunch of
grown men and praying apples alpha males
all over the place you know you know
somebody mentioned to me earlier that
money they play with a JV I'll show what
you play with I've seen quarterbacks
play with worse and come out and fare
better then it's not that they lost the
game prime it's the way they lost the
game our offensive line got dominated
our defensive line got dominated when I
his mind that's the first time all year
I can honestly say they had it took to
him they had it took to them in the
worst way
who do you like in the NFC you know what
he loves yesterday and that was Seattle
I love I like Seattle and I've already
been rolling with the saying since day
one of training camp I like the things
they are a top ten team and what I mean
by that is your defense can either be a
top ten their offerings is a top ten top
three office they got the right coaching
Sean Payton they got the right group of
guys Riley
I like the Saints man they are nice in
the AFC who do you like me oh I hate to
say this but I like the San Diego
Chargers man because they have a top ten
top ten offensive defense their special
teams ain't bad they can get the running
back back they make him do some things a
lot of people question fill of rhythms
drills and it big game abilities but
this maybe is your becomes bowls an
eagle coming off the end for they
dangerous man
they are dangerous we just spoke to
coach Lynn and he said they're peaking
right now at the right time
oh they are he's done a masterful job
man in a duel of coaching these guys I
was he a running back coach I coached me
in what it was his background primacy of
my path he was a coach out running back
coach I think you but he's doing a
masterful job of holding that team
together man and doing it and doing it
the right way man so I'm happy for he's
a running back question question time
huh
he was a running back white running back
coach for quite some time
yes he was he's gonna master a job man
I mean he's demanded that these guys
play the right way they playing the
smart way and they doing what they have
to do now I do i receiver yeah he heard
his Hill has gained it the the primary
gobbler they had a young guy Mike
Williams come come to the right
when he worked yeah he went to work man
Wow hey this is Nate Newton my former
teammate one of my best friends who
we're gonna be neighbors real soon and
we're gonna get old together and joke
together and just destroy each other
emotionally together I'm gonna do what
you I'm allowing you to do what you
always do to me like on a daily basis
you get your last shot and you hang up
in my face you get your last joke off no
I'm not gonna crack any jokes today
Deion Sanders I'm glad that rich eyes
and allows you to come on to these shows
that you cannot expand your knowledge
and arises with all the people in the
world man and I I wish out a much much
success and tell that dude next time
whoever called me to set this up Mary
speaks live in the phone that would help
me you know a lot because I know what I
was listening to there okay
okay well you're not gonna take a shot
at the staff here they're very good
staff okay
and they told me you get your gear they
told me you get out of here out of the
phone it'd be better okay that's what
they told me what my the guy that now
they were talking about he said if you
get your ear out of the phone that he
would be a much more clear
Nate I thank you man I appreciate you
can you guys hang up on Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience